ونرحب الان بالاستاذ باسل الحاج جاسم
الباحث في العلاقات الروسيه والاوروبيه
وخبير في شؤون اسيا الوسطى
والقوقاز اهلا بك استاذ باسل في هذه في
فقره ضيف اليوم التي سنتناول اذا فيها هذه
الاتهامات المتبادله بين كيف وموسكو حول
تحطم طائرات عسكريه امس فوق منطقه بلغورد
ومقتل ركابها موسكو تقول اذا ان الطائره
كانت تقل اسرى حرب اوكرانيين بهدف
مبادلتهم مجلس الامن الدولي سيعقد جلسه
حول هذا الحادث بناء على طلب قدمته
روسيا يعني يقول الروس بالضبط عكس ما
يقوله
الاوكرانيين بالتالي امام ما حدث عمليا
برايك من الذي يقول حقيقه ما جرى بخصوص
هذه
الطائره مساء الخير لك وللمشاهدة كرام في
الواقع قد يكون من المبكر الخروج باحكام
على حقيقه وحيثيات هذه الحادثه معروف في
العامين الماضيين منذ اشتعال هذه المعارك
او ما تسميها روسيا عمليه عسكريه خاصه في
اوكرانيا شهدنا الكثير من حوادث الجو
وخصوصا مع الطائرات العسكريه
الروسيه الواضح اليوم ان هناك ساحه جديده
ضيفت
للمواجهه بين كيف وموسكو بعد المواجهه
السياسيه العسكريه الاعلاميه وحتى في
الجانب القضائي سواء في محكمه العدل
الدوليه او محكمه الجنايات الدوليه اليوم
هذه الحادثه والاتهامات والاتهامات
المبادله تعطينا او تفتح ساحه جديده
للمواجهه بين روسيا و نعم استاذ استاذ
استذ باسل يعني استاذ باسل هو هو
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه حتى او حتى
زيلنسكي
يعني لم ينفوا استهداف الطائره في هذه
المنطقه لانه هذه المنطقه هي منطقه متاخمه
للحدود الاوكرانيه وتتعرض غالبا فيها يعني
هناك هناك هي منطقه عمليات عسكريه عمليا
وكيف تنفذ هجمات عده فيها
اي لكن ل لا زيلينسكي ولا الاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه قالوا انه لم يتم استهداف
الطائره هم فقط قالوا
انهم غير صحيح ان انهم يعرفون ان على متن
الطائره كان هناك اسرى
اوكرانيون تماما لذلك لو نلاحظ موسكو هي
التي سارعت او
بادرت بدايه بالمطالبه بتحقيق دولي في هذه
الحادثه لانه معروف سبق واستهدفت اوكرانيا
طائرات عسكريه روسيه واعترفت بذ ذلك اليوم
قد يزيد هذا الملف او هذه القضيه او موضوع
الطائره تعقيدا بحسب ما تصرح روسيا وجود
65 اسير حرب اوكراني كان يجري الاعداد او
تم نقلهم من اجل الاستعداد لمبادلتهم
ومعروف ملف موضوع تبادل الاسرى تولي سواء
موسكو او كيف اهميه كبرى بالاضافه طبعا ان
الوسطاء الدوليين لم ينجحوا سوى في موضوع
تبادل الاسرى في هذه القضيه او هذه الحرب
المعقده والتي تزداد تعقي تعقيدا قد يكون
هذا البعد يعطيها ربما تعقيدات وابعاد
اخرى تتجاوز موضوع اسقاط طائرات عسكريه في
طبعا في ظل اجواء حرب وهذا شيء طبيعي يعني
من الطبيعي ان تستهدف اوكرانيا الطيران
العسكري ال الروسي وبالمثل من الجانب
الروسي في ظل اجواء الحرب التي نشهدها لكن
وجود اسرع حرب كان جاري استعداد لتبادلها
وفق التصريحات الروسيه قد تضيف تعقيدا اخر
ل والاوكرانيه بالمناسبه استاذ جاسم لان
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه تقول كان من
المفترض ان تجري عمليه تبادل الاسرى
بالفعل هم يقولون لم نكن نعلم ان على متن
الطائره اسرى كما تقول الوايه
الروسيه يعني هنا من الصعب جدا الوقوف على
حقيقه هذه
التصريحات معروفه الاتهامات والاتهامات
المبادله ليس فقط في هذه الحادثه منذ
سنوات
وهناك الكثير ربما من المناكفات وصفها في
اطار الحرب الساخنه التي نشهدها واقتربت
من عامين على بدئها واليوم ايضا قد يكون
من المبكر الوقوف على حقيقه تصريحات
الجانبين سواء الاوكراني او الروسي
لانه مع وجود اسرى حرب اوكران في هذه
الطائره بالفعل اذا ما
ثبت وقوف اوكرانيا وراء الاسقاط ستكون
يعني نقطه لصالح موسكو وستزيد ربما من
الحرج الاوكراني و تصريحات خصوصا بعض
الدول الاوروبيه التي لا تريد استمرار
الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا عندما تتحدث عن
لا احد يعرف اين تذهب هذه الاسلحه وطريقه
استخدامها ا يمكن لحدث من هذا النوع ان
يؤثر على امدادات الغرب لكيف علما بانه
طبعا الغرب اليوم متحفظ ربما اكثر في مكان
ما من قبل بخصوص مد مد كياف باسلحه
معينه يستبعد ان يكون لهذه الحادثه حتى لو
ثبت وقوف اوك اوكرانيا وراء هذه الحادثه
بسبب ان الاسباب الحقيقيه لما نشهده اليوم
من تراجع الدعم الغربي مختلفه تماما
وجذورها مختلفه تماما معروف انه منذ عده
اشهر بات موضوع الدعم الاوكراني داخل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مثابه ورقه
للسجال والمناكفات الداخليه بين الحزبين
الجمهوري
والديمقراطي بعد وصول تيارات شعبو واحزاب
اليمين المتطرف وصعودها في اكثر من بلد
اوروبي ايضا من بين اهداف كثيره رفعتها
خلال حملاتها الانتخابيه هو وقف الدعم
العسكري بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا لذلك هذه الحادثه من المستبعد
يكون لها تاثير لان موضوع الدعم واسباب
تراجعه او حتفه مستقبلا مختلفه تماما عن
طبيعه هذه الحادثه وتاثيرها على سير
المعارك شكرا شكرا لك
استاذ باسل الحاج جاسم الباحث في العلاقات
الروسيه الاوروبيه والخبير في شؤون اسيا
الوسطى والقوقاز شكرا
لك